it's always hard to say goodbye but  that's reportedly exactly what Nintendo  is doing with the wii u i'm tony and  this gamespot news update is out of  production a notice on Nintendo's  japanese site appears to confirm the end  of wii u production the statement  translated by Kotaku reads production is  scheduled to end soon note that this  comes from the japanese site so it may  only refer to that region but rumors  about this sort of thing have been  circling for a while nintendo has  previously denied these so it looks like  we'll have to wait for an official  statement meanwhile the company's next  console the switch is scheduled to  release in march 2017 will hear all the  hot details during than 10 days  presentation on january 12 and will post  all the latest to gamespot for all the  latest nintendo news you're already in  the right place